what is going on Phillip python i'ts
welcome to the fourth debugging tutorial
video in this video we're gonna be
talking about division by zero now I
know you might be thinking well that's
easy enough it just means that we tried
to divide by zero right so we run that
we divide by zero and we get that error
but that we're gonna stop there because
how are we actually gonna arrive at this
problem generally you're gonna write
arrive at this problem when cuz you're
not actually gonna do this like you're
not actually gonna write an equation and
put division by zero instead you're
gonna have a variable that you thought
had something in it and it really was a
zero and at least in my scenario where
I've run into this is when say I have a
variable or a file something like that
and then I'm referencing that file in
some way so let's say a Len Y and I'm
expecting there to be data in there
there's not data and so either maybe I'm
doing like an average of all the numbers
and why what's the average well the
average is zero or maybe I'm doing
literally the length of Y and I'm
expecting there to be a ton of data but
there's not a ton of data like maybe
maybe we have a bunch of sentiment
values and that I'm expecting there to
be a bunch of sentiment values in and Y
X is going to be how many of Y and then
later on we're gonna add everything up
and Y and then divide it by X something
like that who cares but they're
causation is usually you thought the
variable it was populated and it was it
so let's just give a quick example print
and this function does serious business
would prance serious business and then Z
equals 15 divided by X save it run it
and we're gonna run function here and
sure enough you know zero division error
and so think that might be an example of
how you'd arrive at that like I say
usually it's when you expect that
something to be populated and it wasn't
but there might be I don't know maybe
one of you guys is actually gonna try a
division by zero I don't know anyway
that covers division by zero as I
thanks for watching